we've got a great show for y'all today
I'm very stoked take a look at my
audience first of all everyone is
holding a copy of their favorite book I
love this show that's because today we
are continuing my stranger reads
initiative
the idea is very simple sometimes your
best book recommendations can come from
people outside your circle later in the
show we'll all exchange books which I
love and I'm eager to hear what you all
brought I hope I haven't read any of
them but first Today's Show is also full
of amazing women who have wildly
successful careers spanning many years
and including many Academy Awards
together they star in the new movie book
club the next chapter it's in theaters
tomorrow everybody in our book club with
them is already in session right over
here
oh
Candice Bergen Diane Keaton
and Mary surgeon
hello ladies
I'm very excited to see you again I'm so
happy to see you again yes and I'm
excited to see you in person not on Zoom
I know yes too this is you in person and
welcome ladies to the show I'm a big fan
obviously that's an understatement and
we are fans of yours thank you well I'm
going to talk about this because it's in
the movie so let's Dive Right In in the
movie you read The Alchemist which we
all have a copy of I've read this I
actually love it
um so in the story The Character though
learns what he was seeking was actually
back where he started all along which I
love that so what does that mean to you
Mary
um well I came from Arkansas and
um and the more places I go the more I
realize that at the very core of me I
had it all as a child with parents that
loved me and a community that loved me
and it's a great place to come from and
uh but the book also talks about never
losing your sense of adventure and that
getting lost isn't necessarily a bad
thing in life that it's all part of the
adventure I love getting lost sometimes
I'm literally about to take a vacation I
was like I don't want to plan a thing I
just like going somewhere and just
seeing like where it takes you what do
you all feel like from the book did you
like the book The Alchemist did you like
the story the message yeah I love this
quote uh T.S Eliot it's a paraphrase we
spend our life exploring and at the end
of our Explorations we come back to
where we started and know it for the
first time
yeah oh my God I love that well Candace
and Diane do you agree yeah yeah uh yeah
of course I mean what else am I gonna do
duh yeah it's funny though
I'm from a small town and I remember I
was like I can't wait to get out I just
want to do so much I want to see so much
and like it's funny now I live like my
main home is like in a place smaller
than where I grew up like it's even
smaller because you you realize how
precious that was to have space and like
you know your neighbors and you know
everybody in the community it's funny
how that comes full circle did y'all
experience that you're both from
California right I'm from California and
I don't know about her you're from
Beverly Hills I think yeah I am from
Beverly yeah I'm fancy he's in Beverly
Hills I know that's fancy I was from
Highland Park that's right both fancy
speaking well we'll talk more about our
favorite books later but it's also
Mother's Day this Sunday so we want to
celebrate mamas
um Mary
do your do your kids celebrate with you
do you all do anything special they do
but I'm a grandmother now so part of
what I'm celebrating is my daughter Lily
who's just an amazing mother herself and
um yeah it's like the whole any excuse
for our whole gang to just Pile in dogs
kids babies everybody it's wonderful
that is wonderful especially as a
grandma now yeah I I love being a
grandmother it's so boring to say but it
is the greatest
I know it's special it's different we
text each other uh grandmother photos
all the time it's so it must be so odd
to I have a six and eight-year-old but I
can't so obviously I can't imagine but
like to have your kids be mothers you
know what I'm saying like that's that's
interesting that Dynamic like being like
wait you're a mom too that's just weird
I can't look at my eight-year-old and go
I hope you do well like I hope I did
well enough um what about y'all what do
you do leave me out
[Laughter]
right now
we're gonna celebrate for you for
Mother's Day let's take a quick break
Emma from our audience can help with
that hi I'm so glad to be a part of your
book club today the book I brought is
the storied life of AJ Vickery by
Gabrielle zevin it's all about how life
can take unexpected turns and shape you
into a brand new person I loved it it
made me laugh and it made me cry and I
recommend it to everyone more with Kelly
Jane Candace Mary and Diane when we come
back we are back with a cast of book
club the next chapter Jane Fonda Candice
Berg and Diane Keaton embarrassing
virgin
so Gene tell us what happens in the
movie
the nutrient oh the one yeah
we just how much do I give away we
decide I love this movie so much we're
just not the ending that we're gonna go
to Italy I know
um just always a good decision do I say
why
sure yeah sure okay I I I me what's my
character's name
believe it or not and so we decided to
do a bachelorette party in Italy and and
so it's it's our adventures in in Italy
and you know eventually our lovers our
husbands are whoever they are show up
and
and it's like why do we need them yeah
there's a lot I don't care that is us I
got to be with Andy Garcia for a few
minutes it was really fun for me yes he
had to kiss me too
she
hated every second I can't wait to meet
all the men here
oh yeah
Mary did you get to do anything besides
work when you're in Italy did y'all to
get to do anything fun well I took Ted
Danson so that was fun never heard about
and our dog Arthur our 17 and a half
year old puppy dog and
um he was and Ted kind of was
everybody's plus one he took us all out
to dinner and uh I mean the it's the the
food is just and and I she made me get
started on aperol spritzes which I don't
think I'd ever had in my life and then I
had to have one every night breaking my
rule of don't drink when you're working
Mary steenberg and that was out the
window yeah and it doesn't count when
you're in Italy Mary it didn't count and
I had so much fun and I have no regrets
yeah yeah you just say I'm going method
that's what you say in that in that
environment I should have thought of
that this is for my character yeah
exactly
um so the first time everyone here
worked together was the first book club
so Candace um but you and Jane have
known each other for a while right
hundreds of years since
since I was 17. yeah I was my boyfriend
had a crush on her thank you very much
and she's not home yes she knew where he
she lived and so he took me to her house
and we rang the doorbell and and uh
somebody opened it and she at 17 was on
the top of a ladder and I just remember
looking up and thinking
I never want to be around her again this
is the most beautiful human being I have
ever seen in my life and plus she's
brilliant and she's written many books
speaking of books so we go back we go
back I love I love that kind of
friendship and then you get to work
together that's cool yeah yeah well Mary
we've talked talked about your media
pass which I obviously are on the right
show for that um so you wrote a song for
this movie that everybody sings at the
end right yeah it was my love song to
them it's I truly love them and so in
trying to write a song I just thought
it's got to be a love song to them and
it's called anywhere with you and I
wrote it with Caitlyn Smith and Troy
Burgess who you know of from Nashville
yeah and uh before we we didn't have
time to get you to sing it so we sang it
the more of us sing it to each other I
think that's cooler that you all did it
like yeah that's the coolest thing ever
how did y'all feel about singing it it
was wonderful yeah we love the song I
love you you're like I rocked it yeah
I killed it
um so Diane were you surprised that she
was a songwriter did you know that about
Mary I knew that she was yeah musically
inclined and did things like yeah excuse
me but this is Beautiful the song I just
did you hear it I did four musical
skills by the way because I I don't know
if we're ready to pull this up but I
want to pull it up because it's my
favorite thing
um about this interview is you dancing
on Tick Tock you're a hit I don't know I
don't know
because I'm an idiot are you serious no
I am not with this is my stupid I'm not
even it was it to Miley
okay here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
for hours
[Music]
I love it you're like not about it it's
literally like I didn't think I could
love you more and I watched this and I
was like it's the best part is you're
like you're like this looks like a good
spot and then you go for it and then
you're like maybe this and it's I that's
literally me at my house I love dancing
I I own it all the time on this show
when I'm home alone I dance in my house
and I think even in front of my kids
they think I'm nuts but I love dancing
it looks like you feel good when you do
it I had a fun time but I'm a
I am no I don't call that being a
I call that feeling free and like
vulnerable and like awesome yeah I love
that video I was like we're showing it
um and her whole Instagram feed it takes
two hours it's it's brilliant speed and
all of it is she has the one part that's
doors it's just doors you don't want to
miss out on the door
I don't even know if you know this but
you have like blown up on Tick Tock like
literally I have no idea and what is
Tick Tock exactly
I know I get it but like you are like
it's it's insane everybody's like did
you see the video and I'm like I did
it's incredible and you I think it's and
first of all I love doors what are they
like different doors all over yeah I
like the doors yes Oh I thought you
meant like actual Outdoors yeah I used
to do that in Spain when I walked out in
Spain I used to take pictures because
all the doors are architecture they're
amazing that's right yeah and I'm
obsessed with them I'm so safe and wine
so the official title of the new movie
is book club the next chapter so what's
a chapter age in your life that you're
kind of glad that's over mine's my 20s
me too my youth yeah yeah yeah it's
wasted on you it's really hard to be
young yeah my 20s were really difficult
what about y'all
I I just remember on the oldest I've
ever felt in my life was my 30th
birthday and it was just because I was I
was sad there was a lot of stuff not
great in my life and uh and here I was
I'm I just had my 70th birthday and my
70th birthday was spent recording that
song with these guys that Harvey Mason
Jr
I love Harvey Mason and and so that's
what we did and if you had told me at 30
on your 70th birthday you'll be
recording a song that you wrote with
three Legends and you're all singing and
they're your true friends in life and I
would have and they're your words and
they're my words along with my two
co-writers yeah I would have been blown
away but I I didn't so the thing is you
don't know what your journey is going to
be you got to say yes to stuff you know
that you might never dream you would
ever do don't give up
what was millionaire life that you were
like that was really tough I'm glad
that's over
really tough I'm glad it's over every
day I feel that way
obviously you do you up I have
this and I'm not sharing it any day that
didn't have that Kansas what about you
[Laughter]
uh and I was glad to get the young years
out of the way yeah and I think now is a
good time and I'm 76 so I'm hoping I
have a
little more of a clip to go yeah isn't
it interesting though that you think
like I remember in my 20s I was like
okay I got to do everything I got to do
everything fit it all in and this is the
time and it's like honestly Now That I'm
Older I'm 40 and I'm like I'm I'm having
more fun I'm smarter about thing like
wiser about my schedule I'm just you
know you can say no you know what I'm
saying and things are still gonna be
fine your career like it's interesting I
feel like with age just comes wisdom for
some
um not everyone
um but um but it's it's interesting
though that the older you get you're
saying like I'm 76 now and you're still
like you're in this huge movie you're
with friends doing it and it's like
things are still hitting on all
cylinders and I think that's great
incredible I'm stunned and I'm thrilled
yeah me too that's what I was saying
like in 40 who would have thought I had
to talk who'da thought my life would
have taken this this road and I think
it's interesting to say yes to things
that you would have never said yes to
and then you have no idea where that
will take you I love that
um well Mary you've said that the book
club movies help women avoid
experiencing the diminishment plan so
what exactly is that you think
I think there's this sort of Collective
Agreement as we get older that's very
subconscious that we're we're just gonna
we agreed to diminish ourselves and I
just don't think you have to do that and
I know there's hard things and part of
it's how well you take care of your body
and part of its
what what you're dealing with in life
but I also feel like you can fight it
and um Jane Fonda for example uh would
be an example of someone who just
doesn't she refuses to be less vibrant
as she ages actually is true of them all
and um and me too I do try I do care
people get more vibrant I think that's
the whole idea you're still alive you
know I I was saying one day that my only
regrets are that my dad never met Ted I
can't do anything about that because my
dad's gone but my other regret was that
I didn't speak a foreign language and
then I suddenly realized well you're
still alive you can actually yeah so
I've been studying French for two years
which I'm they all speak languages like
up the Wazoo and I'm not very fast at it
but I'm still doing it yeah do it every
day because you can because I think
ageism is a real thing and people think
that once you pass certain thing oh well
that's your vocation you've already
chosen what you're going to do for your
life you've already chosen that that's
not true at all it can completely change
and you can try new things at any age
and I think with more wisdom and more
desire and appreciation yeah I think
women get braver when they get older
absolutely absolutely and because you
know what the hell do we have to lose
yeah why not
excuse like what would you tell your
younger self it's like be braver like
don't don't listen to the the nonsense
the chaos that says what you should be
saying or how you should be acting or
all those things do you agree about like
just growing older and like you can
become more vibrant and more interesting
I think I think that's the case yeah
absolutely when I was a kid I used to go
into a parties I was traumatized by just
the experience of a lot of people but
um but now I'm I'm just I have a barn in
Connecticut I did you say a bar Barn
I'm more interested in the bar you
should have a bar in your barn I have a
bar in my barn
there's no animals It's a Party Barn
Diane you'd love it uh yeah
so Diane how have you been able to avoid
diminishing in your own lives I'll start
with you how do you think you've avoided
that I've always had issues with
diminishing I'd like to yeah I'd like to
head out it's so funny I'm afraid she's
compulsively creative yeah she is I
think she is constantly creative
constantly is she watching her on this
set because we were on these amazing
sets and when you couldn't find her she
was drifting off taking photographs of
something sorry I didn't swear to God it
was working hard yeah she worked hard
because the part is director is right
there yeah he's the director and and the
producer right there oh
I love it like how she's describing
herself as kind of like you know when
you see that kid the like six-year-old
playing you know baseball and he's just
out there yeah that's her that's me
that's nothing but it's true she's right
I love that though I think that that
keeps you young constantly being
creative and constantly like excited
about a project I've always got so many
projects going on I'm not even in the
Limelight right it's in life I like
doing things I think that keeps you
um interesting and excited about life
and engaged and productive yeah and also
it's so amazing what you've done with
your life because the first time I saw
you was on that show it was American
Idol yeah yes I mean my God
it's so interesting yeah and look I'm
more shocked than anyone that it worked
out I can promise you
I'm still shocked
[Music]
[Applause]